Well, I mean, I'm like a APL programmer at heart, not a... Right, right. I think it's like you, you're approaching it like top down, whereas I'm approaching it like bottom up. Yeah. That's what makes us such a, such an awesome pair. Make that the cold open. And the last part of this episode. Welcome to ADSP the podcast, episode 294 recorded on July 9th, 2000.
26. My name is Connor and today with my co-host, Bryce, we chat about the histogram algorithm, histocash, and more. It's going to be fun. It's going to be so much fun. I am going to get to give you a quiz. A quiz? A quiz. About what? I don't think the quiz is going to go well for you. That's fine. All right. All right. Here's the quiz. You are given a graph. And the answer is, or the question is, not the answer. I'll give you the answer eventually. But this is a graph that on the x-axis shows different bin counts,
and on the y-axis shows speed-up. And this is for a histogram algorithm, in particular, a multi-channel histogram algorithm. Multi-channel means a histogram where it outputs to multiple different places. Like if you're doing a histogram over an image, over the pixels in an image, and you want to output different red, green, blue, alpha counts. and the question is for this diagram, why is performance progressing for some of the large bin counts,
but not other of the large bin counts? And all of the information that you need to answer this is on the graph. You don't need to see the code. The answer is very simple. And we will see whether you can get there. So in particular,
this graph shows the perf from bin counts starting at 16 to 12K bins. But the wording of my question is we're only interested in the performance of the 32K bins up to the 1,024K bins. Well, first of all, let's take a step. step back and understand multi-channel histogram. So all it means is you're just, you're binning multiple things instead of a single
thing. That's all it means. You are taking one for like, like when you take your value in for histogram, in this case here, your value is something that you're decomposing into multiple constituent parts.
The example I gave was like a pixel where you know, it has a red, a green, a blue, and an alpha component. So you have some composite thing that is your value, and the output is going to multiple different
output locations. So you're splitting it up into its components. Or like if you have like a a 3D point value, like a 3D point struct that have an X, Y, and Z coordinate, your histogram
algorithm in this case would a separate output histogram for the x's, a separate for the y's, and a separate for the z's. Okay, that makes sense. And yeah, you've got speed up on the y-axis, and then on the x-axis, you have zero all the way up to a million, because it's a thousand, thousand. Yeah. And at the 32,000 mark, there's a degradation right there. and then it pops back up,
and then at 64,000, it degrades again. So, obviously, those are both powers of two. Ah, interesting. Interesting. Those are both powers of two. Well, I mean,
everything I guess technically on the x-axis is a power of two. It's not like I'm Sherlock Holmes here. Is it? Is it? Oh, yeah, that's true. It's not. a lot of them are well it goes 1632 64 128 256 512 1, 1,000 and I'm assuming that's
1024 uh but then in between 32 and 64 is 48 and 56 which is rather odd because other than those two I will I will I will give you an information here that is not applicable to the solution of the problem, but explains why 56K is on this graph. The reason that 56K is on this graph is because that is the number of 32-bit bins that you can fit into shared memory on a Nvidia B-200 GPU. And so that bin count was important to include on here for the single-channel case. And this is the multi-channel case. It just happened to be that when I did the benchmark sweep, that it included that point here. And 48K, I think, was put on here because we were interested in more granular information about the performance between 32K and 64K. So 56K was like a specific,
interesting case that we wanted to look at it's not applicable here because in the case of the multi-channel histogram you need like if for the single channel you can fit
56 bins then for the multi-channel you can only fit 56k divided by however many channels you have in this case we always have four channels but it is beneficial that we did include the 56K bin count on here because it helped us learn something.
Oh, and I didn't read the tweet. The tweet says that the correct answer is one word? Yes. That's, I think, me being a little bit cheeky, but the answer is not complicated. Or the answer I will accept is not complicated. Well, that's not true. The answer is complicated.
However, you really only have to name the general area that the problem is in to get the answer correct here. So, take a step back. No, no, no. You're going to get there. You've already identified one of the key pieces of this, which is, so from 32K to 1224K, Look at all of the ones that regress. What do all the ones that are regress have in common? That they're a power of two.
Right. And all the ones that don't regress are... It's just the 48 and 56, so... Yes. But I tell you, if you did any other non-power of two, it would not regress. What do you know about the histogram algorithm? Or what do you know about histogram in general? And what do I know about your algorithm?
And the implementation. What do you know about the nature of solving a histogram? The nature? Like, what are the bottlenecks in computing a histogram? Does it do a lot of compute? Depends on the implementation. You believe that there's an implementation of histogram that does a lot of compute? Of course you can construct a compute-intensive
What is the compute? By compute, I mean, you know, arithmetic. I mean, the easiest way to implement this in an array language. Well, is it the easiest? Is to do a, well, it depends on, yeah, the bins and whatnot. But if you have like a, you know, every value gets its own bin, you just do an outer product and then a reduction on every row. Okay. So an outer product and reduction, what is the arithmetic intensity of those operations?
Arithmetic intensity? Is histogram more like a matmole or a mem copy? Is histogram more like matmole or more like mem copy? It's definitely not like mem copy. Would I say it's like matmole? Not really, but I, I guess if I have to choose, I'll choose Matmole. But I feel like I'm getting, you're trying to lead me,
you're trying to lead a horse to water and you're failing. How many, in Matmo, what are the, what are the operations that you're doing? You're doing multiplication and addition. And also addition. Multiplications and additions. Roughly, order of magnitude, how many multiplications and additions are you doing? doing? Is it a linear number? No. No.
It's like it's in cubed or n squared depending on whether you're doing batch or whatnot. But like let's, you know, it's nonlinear, right? Okay, you're doing a lot of flops. Depends on the size of your matrix, right? And it depends on whether you're doing
it, you know, whether it's a sparse mat mall, like structured spars, etc. But like a dense mat mat mall, nonlinear. Okay. So you said it's doing multiplications and additions on the values. Are you doing multiplications and additions in a histogram? You're doing additions.
Okay, you're doing additions. That's correct. What type of additions are you doing? You're adding ones and zeros. Well, you're always adding ones and zeros, technically. Are you adding, let's assume, let's pretend here that our, let's pretend here that our, our histogram input type is floating point numbers. Okay. So assume that it's FP64.
When you're doing your histogram, are you adding those FP64 values together? No. What are you adding? Ones and zeros. Okay, you're adding ones and zeros. What data type are you adding? Whatever integer you decide to represent your bin counts. So you are adding integers.
Mm-hmm. Okay. In Matmole, are you adding integers? Not all the time. Let's assume we're doing an FP-64, a floating point. Okay. Okay. So, in your histogram, in your, in your map mall, you're doing floating point multiplications
and additions in a non-linear. Right? Sure. In histogram, you are only doing integer additions. What? How many are you doing? The count of the number of values you have? You're also doing comparisons to potentially. What is the big O complexity?
Linear? And also too, the reason I zoned out for a sec was because, like this is all dependent on your implementation. Like I said, if you're doing an outer product... It's not... It is. It is. If you're doing an outer product and then summing each of those rows, that's a quadratic amount of work.
It's not linear. Like the implementation that we're talking about where you just go one by one, sure, that's linear. But like an outer product, you're going to do a quadratic or not a quadratic amount of work. Yeah, that is quadratic. Because you're going to, yeah, yeah, I'm correct. And it all, yeah.
So it depends on the implementation. You want to talk me through how it's quadratic? Yeah. Say you've got 10 elements, an outer product, an equality outer product on a 10 element array is going to give you a 10 by 10 matrix, which is 100 values. And then you're going to do a linear reduction on each row of that matrix, which is a square.
So you're doing a quadratic amount of work. Like each reduction is linear. But if you're doing a reduction on a Boolean mask, that was the result of an equality with each element with the rest. Anyways, That's why when you were talking about the bites thing, which kind of is, I don't understand the point of this thought exercise. But I was thinking like, wait a second, like, depending on the implementation, you could be doing more than a linear amount of work. Anyways, that's why, that's why I was, I didn't actually zone out.
I started thinking that, like, what are we talking about here? We're talking in the, in the abstract about an algorithm that we haven't actually described. And the things we were saying may or may not be true dependent on what the algorithm actually is. Okay. Let's do some quick math. There are 148 SM cores on a B200. This is like going to be, is this episode even going to air? We're going to have to record for an hour because we're going to toss this episode. This episode is going to air.
This episode's going to air. I mean, I feel like didn't we have a disagreement at one point on some algorithm that was like you were arguing? I've got to go figure it out. Oh, yeah, is it more similar to a Transform or something? And I still, like, even describing all this stuff, like, a MemCopy is just copying. It's just moving.
What is the dominant operation in a MemCopy? Maybe a Transform. How about a Transform? A Transform is a better example. Is it more like a Transform or a MapMol? Or is it, how about this?
Is it more like a vector ad or a mat-mol. I don't know. I still think it's more similar to a mat-mull than anything you've mentioned. I mean, this is the thing. This is why I bring up that previous example because, like, I refuse to agree
that something was more similar to something, but it's just because, like, my categorized... The way that I categorize things is different than the way you think about, like, the things that it's doing under the hood. I look at, like, the shape. Like, if you look at what Matmole does, it takes something in one shape
某种东西与其他东西更相似，但那只是因为，比如说，我分类的方式……我给事物分类的方式，与你思考它在底层所做事情的方式不同。我关注的是，比如形状。如果你看看 Matmole 做的事情，它把某种形状的东西
and turns it into a different shape. If you look what MemCopy does, or if you look what Transform does, or if you look what Vector Ad does, it takes something in one shape. The shape doesn't change, and it's just the values that change. Histogram does something that's more similar to the Matmole
转换成另一种形状。如果你看看 MemCopy 做什么，或者 Transform 做什么，或者 Vector Ad 做什么，它都是把一种形状的东西输入进去。形状没有变，只有值发生了改变。Histogram 做的事情与 Matmole 更相似
in that, like, you have data, and then you get something with a different shape that's just based on the values of those data. But you're thinking about this in terms of what the algorithm does. I'm thinking about this in terms of what are the bottlenecks limiting the performance of the of the algorithm. I don't care what the algorithm does.
在于，你有数据，然后你得到一个不同形状的东西，这仅仅是基于这些数据的数值。但你考虑这个问题时，是从算法的角度出发的。我考虑这个问题时，是从限制算法性能的瓶颈是什么的角度出发的。我不在乎算法做什么。
I'm just thinking about what are the limiting factors of the algorithm. Well, then you have to phrase your question differently. Like you can't say like, oh, which one is more similar if like, to me, the implied statement there is based on like what the algorithm does. And you're saying, oh, it's based on some other characteristic. That's fair. But this is why I think this is an interesting problem, because you and I look at an algorithm in a completely different way.
我只考虑算法的限制因素是什么。好吧，那你得换一种方式来提问。比如你不能说，哦，哪个更相似，如果在我看来，其中隐含的陈述是基于算法做什么的。而你说，哦，这是基于其他一些特征。这很公平。但这就是为什么我认为这是一个有趣的问题，因为你和我看待算法的方式完全不同。
I look at it from the bottom up, from the performance side. You look at it from the top down from the algorithmic side. So that whatever weird performance effect we're seeing has something to do with the memory subsystem. Well, that was a very boring 28 minutes to get to that single statement. All right. So in a histogram, when you're doing the store, the store, stores generally the expensive part because you have to somehow synchronize updates from different
我是自下而上地从性能端来看待它的。你是自上而下地从算法端来看待它的。所以无论我们看到的奇怪性能效应是什么，都与内存子系统有关。好吧，花了整整 28 分钟才得出这唯一的结论，真是无聊透顶。好了。所以在直方图中，当你执行存储操作时，存储通常是开销最大的部分，因为你必须以某种方式同步来自不同
threats, right? So it would typically go through Atomics. So the bottleneck here is not actually the compute or the loading for the most part, except in some cases where you have low contention. The bottleneck primarily is the speed at which you can store the data into the result because you have to ensure that you store it in a data-safe way, which means you need to use Atomics. So I'll tell you the other thing. This weird performance effect does not happen for the single-channel version. So most cache subsystems are banked,
线程的更新，对吧？所以它通常会通过原子操作（Atomics）来完成。因此这里的瓶颈实际上大部分时候不是计算或加载，除了在某些低冲突（contention）的情况下。瓶颈主要是你将数据存入结果的速度，因为你必须确保以数据安全的方式存储，这意味着你需要使用原子操作。所以我来告诉你另一件事。这种奇怪的性能效应在单通道版本中是不会发生的。所以大多数缓存子系统都是分块的（banked），
which means that when routing requests through the cache, based on the the memory address where the request is going to it gets routed to a different part of the cache subsystem now in our case here
这意味着在通过缓存路由请求时，根据请求要去的内存地址，它会被路由到缓存子系统的不同部分。现在在我们的这个案例中
this is a multi-channel histogram so when we load one value like a pixel we then split it into its four constituent parts and then we have to issue four stores into the memory
这是一个多通道直方图，所以当我们加载一个值（比如一个像素）时，我们会把它拆分成四个组成部分，然后我们必须向内存子系统发出四个存储操作
subsystem that are going to hit four separate memory addresses to store the increment of the count for those four constituent parts. In this case where we have these power of two bins, the last bits of the address, for all of these four addresses, all four of these bins are a power of two size. and they all have the same alignment and they're all going to have the same last set of bits and so when they go through the cash subsystem all four of these store requests are going to get sent
它们会命中四个独立的内存地址，以存储这四个组成部分的计数的增量。在这种拥有 2 号幂（power of two）大小的分箱（bin）的情况下，这四个地址的最后几位，这四个分箱的大小都是 2 的幂。而且它们具有相同的对齐方式，并且它们的最后几位也会相同，所以当它们穿过缓存子系统时，这四个存储请求都会被发送
to the same part of the cash, to the same bank in the cash when they're a power of two size because the cash happens to be power of two sized or rather the way that the cash routes requests happens to be based on, you know, some of the low bits of the address. When we have a non-power-of-two bin count, then the last bits of the address of each of the channels is different. And so they get routed to different L2 banks.
到缓存的同一部分，即缓存中的同一个 bank 中，因为缓存的大小刚好是 2 的幂，或者不如说，缓存路由请求的方式碰巧是基于，你知道的，地址的某些低位。当我们有非 2 的幂的分箱数量时，每个通道地址的最后几位是不同的。因此它们会被路由到不同的 L2 bank。
and that is why if we do 64K, we see substantially worse performance than if we do 64K plus one bins. Now, the interesting thing is how you solve a problem like this. There's a couple of ways. One, you can change your data structure. So the data structure that we're using here is a structive arrays. So each individual channel has its own arrays.
这就是为什么如果我们使用 64K 的分箱，性能会比使用 64K 加 1 个分箱时明显差得多。现在，有趣的是你如何解决这样的问题。有好几种方法。第一，你可以改变你的数据结构。所以我们这里使用的数据结构是结构体数组（struct of arrays）。因此每个单独的通道都有它自己的数组。
So we have one block of memory. for all of the red components, all the green components, all the blue components, all the alpha components. You could change your data structure to a data structure where you instead, you know, just have one, you know, you have the RGBA right next to each other. But in that case, you've just got a single-channel histogram. Like the person who chooses this multi-channel histogram algorithm has intentionally decided that they want to have all of the individual components segregated into their own array where they're densely packed. The other way that you can solve this problem is by padding. So when you allocate the storage for these channels, you make sure that you put some space in between each of those allocations. Usually the best way to do it
所以我们有一块内存，用于所有的红色分量、所有的绿色分量、所有的蓝色分量、所有的 alpha 分量。你可以将你的数据结构更改为另一种数据结构，在其中你只需，你知道的，让 RGBA 紧挨着彼此。但在那种情况下，你其实就只有一个单通道直方图。就像选择这个多通道直方图算法的人，他们刻意决定要将所有单独的组成部分隔离到它们自己的、紧密打包的数组中一样。你可以解决这个问题的另一种方法是使用填充（padding）。因此，当你为这些通道分配存储空间时，你要确保在每个分配之间留出一些空间。通常最好的方法是
is to do one big allocation and put the padding in yourself. manually because if you do four separate allocations of a power of two-sized chunk, you're likely to get addresses that are right after each other and that have this unfortunate alignment where they're all going to end up hashing into the same L2 bank. And so what you instead do is you allocate one big chunk of memory and then you put a little bit of padding space in between each channel's storage, such that their addresses will hash differently. And of course, I probably would have gotten to the bottom of this if I hadn't added the 48K and 56K bin counts here. But many years ago, like 10 years ago, when I was working at Berkeley Lab on writing high-performance tri-diagonal
进行一次大的内存分配，然后自己手动添加填充。因为如果你对一个 2 的幂大小的块进行四次单独的分配，你很可能会得到紧挨着的地址，并且具有这种不幸的对齐方式，它们最终都会哈希到同一个 L2 bank 中。所以你改用的方法是分配一大块内存，然后在每个通道的存储空间之间留出一点填充空间，这样它们的地址哈希出来就会不同。当然，如果我没有在这里添加 48K 和 56K 的分箱数量，我可能早就找出原因了。但是多年前，大约 10 年前，当我在劳伦斯伯克利国家实验室（Berkeley Lab）为当时的英特尔至强融核（Intel Xeon Phi）芯片编写高性能三对角（tri-diagonal）
solvers for the Intel Xion Phi chips of the time, I ran into a very similar, effect like this. And had to do a similar trick with adding padding to it. And actually, that is what motivated me to go to the C++ committee because I wanted to make sure that we added a proper multidimensional
求解器时，我遇到了一个非常类似的效应。并且不得不对它采取类似的添加填充的技巧。实际上，这也是促使我去 C++ 委员会的原因，因为我想确保我们为 C++ 添加了一个适当的多维
array abstraction to C++. And in particular, that we added one that would support arbitrary layouts so that you could express a layout that has padding in between the dimensions. Because one way that you can add this padding is conceptually if you think about the big block of allocation for the channels as being a multi-dimensional array, where one dimension is what channel am I on and the other dimension is how many bins are in that channel. One way you can add the padding is by adding a dimension in between those two that adds the stride that you
数组抽象。特别是，我们要添加一个支持任意布局的抽象，以便你可以表达在维度之间具有填充的布局。因为你可以添加这种填充的一种方法是，从概念上讲，如果你把通道的大块分配视为一个多维数组，其中一个维度是你处于哪个通道，另一个维度是该通道中有多少个分箱。你可以添加填充的方法之一，就是在两者之间增加一个维度来添加你
want. Anyways, I looked at this graph and it took me like three minutes and I was immediately like, ah, this is some sort of L2 cash, you know, bank conflict effect. So what's the single word? Memory? Cash. Oh, man. And just after having had a great episode where we had lots of great feedback on the GitHub discussion and, you know, one person DM'd me. And then we go and do this. This was maybe one of the worst episodes. I think the people are going to love it. I think you're going to get great feedback on this.
想要的跨距（stride）。不管怎样，我看了看这个图表，花了大约三分钟，然后我马上就觉得，啊，这某种程度上是 L2 缓存 bank 冲突效应。那么，那个唯一的词是什么？内存？缓存。哦，天哪。就在我们刚做完一期很棒的节目、收到了很多关于 GitHub 讨论的精彩反馈之后，你知道的，有人给我发了私信。然后我们就去做了这个。这可能是最糟糕的一期节目之一。我觉得大家会喜欢它的。我觉得你会收到关于这个的极佳反馈。
And like also too, like they're not what they're not looking at this graph. Like did we even describe the graph well enough? And we never even actually described the algorithm. And that's my, that's my problem is that like technically. you know, you say, oh, there's only really one at all, all algorithms, and they're not really. Like, I was thinking, like, if you have a low enough number of bins, which clearly you don't based on this graph, but, like, if you only are got, you know, I don't know what the right threshold is, but, like, you could just have every, you know, if you're chunking this up,
而且，就像，他们也没有在看这个图表。我们甚至把图表描述得足够清楚了吗？而且我们实际上甚至从来没有描述过算法。这就是我的问题，从技术上讲，
every, you know, set of threads could just have their own array. And, and then basically you just add those together. and then you avoid all your atomic's issues, you know? We call that privatization, but you still, like, you can do, you can have every thread have their own bins, but you can also have every group of threads have their own bins. And that's what the lower bin count algorithms do, is that every group of threads has their own bin,
你知道，你可能会说，哦，其实只有一种算法，其实并不是。我就在想，如果你有足够少的分箱，显然根据这个图表来看你并没有，但如果你只有，你知道的，我不知道正确的阈值是多少，但你可以让每个，如果你在分块处理，
their own set of bins that live in shared memory, and the fast GPU memory. and then at the end they merge their local privatized bins together so anyways I think I think the problem with this
它们自己的一组箱子存放在共享内存和快速的 GPU 内存中，最后它们将各自私有化的箱子合并在一起，所以无论如何，我认为这个问题
is with this episode is that you went in assuming a ton of stuff and you just said oh all algorithm implementations are the same and yet already here now this is the interesting part is that like you're actually dispatching to a different algorithm based on the size of the bin and you just we just like kind of blanketly said
在于这一期的节目中，你带着一堆假设进来了，你只是说，哦，所有算法的实现都是一样的，但在这里，有趣的部分是，实际上根据箱子的大小，你正在调度到不同的算法，而我们只是随口说
like oh there's only one algorithm they're all the same and that's like just demonstrably false. For the points we're looking at the graph, it's all one algorithm. So the problem with the approach you just described is what do you do when you have a larger number of bins? I mean, it's just not going to work, right? Well, when you just have too many bins
哦，只有一个算法，它们都一样，这显然是错误的。对于我们正在查看图形的点，这完全是一个算法。所以你刚才描述的方法的问题在于，当你有大量的箱子时该怎么办？我的意思是，这根本行不通，对吧？好吧，当你有的箱子太多时
to store a local copy of the whole histogram? You're just not, I mean, that would be a terrible idea. To have that many, just to have that many bins? No, no, no, no, to store a local copy. Like I said, you need to have, like, a number of bins that's below some threshold. I don't know what it is, but, like, you know. But then what's the thing that you should do when you have a larger number of bins? The algorithm that you've alluded to that we haven't talked about, where, you know, you're protecting a single one with Atomics so that you can do updates and whatnot.
以至于无法存储整个直方图的本地副本？你根本不会，我的意思是，那会是个糟糕的主意。为了拥有那么多箱子？不，不，不，不，是为了存储本地副本。就像我说的，你需要拥有数量低于某个阈值的箱子。我不知道具体是多少，但，你知道的。但接下来，当你有更多的箱子时，你应该做什么？你所暗示的那个我们还没讨论过的算法，你知道的，用原子操作保护其中一个，以便你可以进行更新等等。
Yeah, but the problem is that if you have a lot of contention, if you have, if it ends up, you, you, you have, if it ends up, you, you, you, you have. a lot of bins, but most values go into just a few bins, then you have a lot of contention. And then that becomes very slow, because you have a ton of atomics going to a couple of bins and your performance tanks, because all the atomics on any individual bin gets serialized. So there's a couple different things you can do. You can still do a privatized histogram, but you just, you can't have it be local to the thread. You have to allocate dynamic storage for it. And that's what Cub currently does today, which is a little bit slower. This algorithm, which is entirely something that an LLM came up with during auto research,
是的，但问题是，如果你有很大的竞争，如果你有，如果最终，你，你，你，你有，如果最终，你，你，你，你有许多箱子，但大多数值只进入少数几个箱子，那么你就会有很大的竞争。然后这会变得非常慢，因为有大量的原子操作涌向几个箱子，你的性能就会崩溃，因为对任何单个箱子的原子操作都被串行化了。所以你可以做几件不同的事情。你仍然可以做一个私有化的直方图，但你不能让它局限于线程。你必须为它分配动态存储。这就是 Cub 目前正在做的事情，它稍微慢一点。这个算法完全是 LLM 在自动研究期间想出来的，
is one where I call it histocash, where you build a small cache, like a small hash table, basically, for some of the bins in shared memory. And so for bins that are more frequently used, or in this case just a lucky set of bins, because there's no eviction, they get to use the local storage, and then for other bins, they have to go up directly to the global memory.
我称之为 histocash，你建立一个小缓存，基本上是一个小哈希表，用于共享内存中的一些箱子。因此，对于更频繁使用的箱子，或者在这种情况下只是一组幸运的箱子，因为没有驱逐机制，它们可以使用本地存储，而对于其他箱子，它们必须直接去全局内存。
But one of the advantages of the advantage of, having the cash is if you all if most of your values are only going to a small number of bins, then the cash will absorb it. And if your values are evenly distributed with a large number of bins, then it doesn't matter if the cash misses because you don't have a lot of contention. So the atomics going to the global memory are mostly cheap because they're not contended. And the interesting thing about the caching algorithm is it's the only way like you don't if you knew about the structure of your input if you knew oh most of my values are concentrated ahead of time then you could pick a better algorithm but the problem is you don't have a way of knowing that and having a
但拥有缓存的一个优势是，如果你所有的或大部分的值只流向少量的箱子，那么缓存就会吸收它们。如果你的值均匀分布在大量的箱子中，那么缓存未命中也无所谓，因为你没有太多的竞争。因此，去往全局内存的原子操作大多是廉价的，因为它们没有竞争。缓存算法有趣的地方在于，它是唯一的方法，就像你不需要，如果你事先知道输入的结构，如果你知道，哦，我的大部分值都是集中在一起的，那么你可以选择一个更好的算法，但问题是你无法事先知道这一点，并且拥有一个
little cache lets you have one behavior when your values are concentrated and a different behavior when your values are not concentrated oh how am i going to edit this i mean that last part was interesting histo-cash histo-cash maybe that's the name of the episode at least it'll have a good title yeah it's interesting
小缓存可以让你在值集中的时候表现出一种行为，而在值不集中的时候表现出另一种行为。哦，我要怎么编辑这个？我的意思是最后一部分很有趣，histo-cash，histo-cash，也许这就是这一期节目的名字，至少它会有一个好标题。是的，这很有趣，
because the cash that I use it does not evict because it would be too expensive to do an eviction so the cache is it's directly probed so what you do is
因为我使用的缓存不会驱逐，因为驱逐的代价太高了，所以这个缓存是直接探测的，所以你要做的是
you get a value you go and you find your bin and then you look up where your bin should be in the cash and if somebody else has already claimed that spot then you just you've missed in the cash
你得到一个值，去找到你的箱子，然后你在缓存中查找你的箱子应该在的位置，如果其他人已经占用了那个位置，那么你的缓存就未命中，
and you go to global memory but if nobody's claimed that spot then you get to claim that spot and so it's nice because it's a very cheap cash the cost of a miss and the cost of a hit are very very cheap the downside is that you know if somebody's claimed your slot you're just screwed interesting and so there are some adversarial there are some adversarial inputs
然后你去全局内存，但如果没有人占用那个位置，你就可以占用那个位置，所以这很好，因为它是一个非常便宜的缓存，未命中的代价和命中的代价都非常非常低。缺点是，你知道，如果有人占用了你的槽位，你就完蛋了。有趣的是，所以有一些对抗性的，有一些对抗性的输入，
I'll show you a public implementation of this uh people I'm in the process of upstreaming it to cub so by the time this airs there should be a PR open maybe I guess this is airing tomorrow I was going to say it's airing tomorrow maybe not cool There's a bunch of different infrastructures that you have to look at, which is one of the interesting things with this problem. Like, if you just have, like, if all of your values are in one bin, then this works very well because you're always going to hit in the cache. And if they're sort of, like, randomly distributed,
我会向你展示一个公开的实现，呃，我正在将其向上游合并到 cub，所以当这期节目播出时，应该有一个打开的 PR，也许，我猜这期节目明天播出，我正想说它明天播出，也许不会。酷。有许多不同的基础设施你需要看，这也是这个问题有趣的地方之一。就像，如果你只有，比如，如果你的所有值都在一个箱子里，那么这非常管用，因为你总能在缓存中命中。如果它们有点像随机分布的，
you're going to have a pretty good cash hit rate. But you have to, like, kind of work hard to construct an algorithm. Like, this here is a specific construct. where, like, you can construct an adversarial input where you calculate, like, what two bins will collide, and then you first poison the cache by filling the bin with, by filling the slot in the cache, that you're going to then fill the rest of your input sequence with values that would go to that slot. and then miss. And if you do that, then, yeah,
你的缓存命中率会相当不错。但你必须，有点像努力构建一个算法。就像这里是一个具体的结构，你可以构建一个对抗性输入，计算出哪两个箱子会冲突，然后你首先通过填充箱子来污染缓存，通过填充缓存中的槽位，然后用会流向该槽位的值填充输入序列的其余部分，
the performance is pretty atrocious. But a lot of the, like, reasonable inputs that would represent real data it does pretty good on. I mean, this one's, like, kind of mad. But anyways, yeah, histocash. I think it's pretty clever. I will tell you, Bradley,
然后未命中。如果你这样做，那么，是的，性能相当糟糕。但许多代表真实数据的合理输入，它的表现相当不错。我的意思是，这个有点，像，疯狂。不管怎样，是的，histocash。我认为这相当聪明。我告诉你，布拉德利，
Bradley got this quiz right in, like, I don't know, three or four minutes. That's Bradley Dice, our coworker. Have we had Bradley on this podcast? I think we might have. We have not. We have not had Bradley on the podcast, really? No.
布拉德利在三四分钟内就答对了这道测验。那是布拉德利·戴斯（Bradley Dice），我们的同事。我们让布拉德利上过这个播客吗？我想我们可能上过。我们没有。我们没有让布拉德利上过播客，真的吗？没有。
Unless if I'm forgetting, but I don't really forget that kind of thing yet, at least. So it's interesting. You, my first instinct when I look at an algorithm, is to think about the bottlenecks. Well, I mean, I'm like a APL programmer at heart, not a... Right, right.
除非我记错了，但我至少现在不怎么忘那种事。所以这很有趣。你，当我看到一个算法时，我的第一直觉是考虑瓶颈。嗯，我的意思是，我本质上是一个 APL 程序员，而不是一个……对，对。
I think it's like, like you, you're approaching, it like top down, whereas I'm approaching it like bottom up. Yeah. That's what makes us such an awesome pair. Make that the cold open. And the last part of this episode. Be sure to check these show notes, either in your podcast app or at ADSP thepodcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a get-up discussion
我觉得这就像，你，你是自顶向下接近它的，而我是自底向上接近它的。是的。这就是为什么我们能成为如此棒的搭档。把这个做成片头。以及这一期的最后一部分。请务必查看这些节目笔记，无论是在你的播客应用中还是在 ADSP thepodcast.com 上，以获取我们在今天的节目中提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个 GitHub 讨论的链接，
where you can leave thoughts, comments, and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. Low quality, high quantity. That is the tagline of our podcast. That's not the tagline. Our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。感谢收听。希望你喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。低质量，高质量。这就是我们播客的标语。那不是标语。我们的标语是带着零星信息的混乱。这一期还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来留下评论。